en face au co vie d'un dispositif
sanitaire allégé donc depuis aujourd'hui
dans les écoles maternelles et
élémentaires de france avec plusieurs
objectifs éviter les fermetures inutile
garder le plus possible de classe et
d'école ouverte alors faut-il maintenir
ouvertes coûte que coûte ces écoles en
dépit du regain de l'épidémie
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec kevin bosse fait professeur
d'histoire bonsoir à vos côtés alain tu
as le professeur également écho
secrétaire snuipp fsu du nord alors où
le disait première journée de ce
protocole sanitaire allégé dans les
écoles garder le plus possible de place
et des call ouverte c'est le bon cap
selon vous alain palausse effectivement
il faut que les élèves et les enfants
puissent aller à l'école le plus
possible on s'est retrouvé trop éloigné
de l'école pour beaucoup d'enfants
pendant presque six mois donc que les
écoles restent ouvertes oui maintenant à
quelles conditions
si on veut effectivement que les enfants
puissent bénéficier ou de scolarité
satisfaisante qu'ils puissent continuer
à apprendre et rattraper le
éventuellement le retard qu'ils ont pu
avoir depuis depuis 13 mars il faut s'en
donner les moyens et dans la pression
que la le protocole signé cherche plutôt
inverse
il faut ouvrir coûte que coûte quitte à
ce que le virus se continue de se
propager que des enfants soient
contaminés et surtout que il le ramène à
la maison et c'est peut-être ce qui nous
inquiète le plus kevin boss fait c'est
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on nous coûte
que coûte finalement sans faire
attention réellement au protocole on ça
passe en second plan c'est comme ça vous
voyez la situation est également non
absolument pas on a un ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer justement ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui fait tout pour
que tous les enfants puissent avoir
accès à l'école donc il est parfaitement
normal si vous voulez qu'on allège le
protocole sanitaire afin de permettre à
tous les enfants de pouvoir bénéficier
dans l'enseignement dit il faut dire
pendant le confinement il ya plein
d'enfants qui ont été privés notamment
d'écoles donc l'égalité c'est quoi
l'égalité c'est de rouvrir au maximum
ces écoles notamment pour faire vivre
l'école de la république pour faire
revivre l'une des valeurs les plus
fondamentales de notre république c'est
à dire l'accès à tous à l'éducation donc
jean-michel blanquer a mis en place
notamment tout un tas de protocole a
fourni des masses aux enseignants a
fourni du jet li drôle que à hydro
alcooliques dans nos classes et tout est
réunit maintenant pour qu'on puisse
convenablement enseigner et pour qu'on
puisse notamment être à la hauteur du
défi qui nous attend
alors alain le tout est réuni nous
sommes à la hauteur du défi qui nous
attend selon kevin bossuet vous cochez
la tête vous n'êtes pas d'accord
visiblement qu'estimant pour vous je ne
sais pas je pense qu'on doit penser
mieux
dans le même temps m dans le temps mais
ministère mais moi j'ai pas eu de gel
hydroalcoolique
j'ai eu cinq provinces compter en
textile qui sont aux normes depuis une
semaine qui est lié qui ne l'étaient pas
et qui ne seront peut pas enseigner avec
je suis désolé mais moi aussi je veux
absolument que les enfants mes enfants
que mes élèves puissent aller à l'école
de blanc commission et pour ça je le
redis il faut qu'on s'en donne les
moyens
alors on nous dit que les enfants ne
sont pas contaminés c'est faux c'est
complètement faux les chiffres qu'on a
vu des inspecteurs académiques de dieu
de lille la semaine dernière mais que
mercredi 6 117 cas sur cinq cent
quarante cinq mille enfants ça veut dire
à peu près un peu plus de 100 pour cent
mille on est au dessus de la moyenne
nationale
on est un petit peu au dessus la moyenne
dans le département du nord 157
enseignants sur environ 30000 premier
second degré contaminées dans le
département du nord
on est à cinq cent pour cent mille je
veux bien qu'on me dise que le virus est
à sens unique que les enfants ne compte
elle ne se contaminent pas entre eux et
ne contaminent pas les enseignants les
parents mais c'est pas là c'est pas
c'est pas ça le virus continue de
circuler et les enfants entre eux
continuent de devant la trappe et donc
si on veut vraiment que les enfants
puissent continuer d à l'école parce que
je pense que là tu ans rejoint et puisse
continuer d'apprendre et c'est une
valeur fondamentale de la république et
où nous y sommes attachés aux os ni pépé
il faut peut-être réfléchir à faire en
sorte que ces enfants puissent
bénéficier dans tout dans une forme de
sécurité sanitaire c'est à dire que
peut-être qu'il faut réduire les groupes
peut-être qu'il faut appliquer une
véritable distanciation sociale parce
que là allez y naturel n'est pas
appliquée peut-être qu'effectivement il
faut que les enfants puissent se laver
les mains se nettoyer les mains avec du
cidre et du gel hydroalcoolique et
qu'ils soient fournis mais ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale ne fournit pas de
gel hydroalcoolique mangeant n'est pas
dans ma classe et points suivants c'est
ce qui est catastrophique c'est le
nombre d'enseignants le haut niveau du
concours
on est passé dans l'académie de lille
2700 pour premier second degré à 1000
milles 92 ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que à un moment donné on a besoin de
plus d'enseignants parce que les enfants
ont été privés d'école pendant trop
longtemps on diminue le nombre de postes
aux concours
on avait 700 postes dans l'académie de
lille en 2019 au concours de professeur
des écoles
il y en a 500 donc alors qu' on aurait
pu juste maintenir le nombre de postes
aux concours
ils sont baissé de 200 dans quelles
conditions les enfants vont ils être
accueillis et puis si on ajoute à ça le
problème de d'absence non remplacés qui
sont liées effectivement aussi au fait
que ben voilà dans le protocole il ya
des enseignants qui vont être malade il
faut qu'on puisse faire en sorte que les
actions soient remplacés que les enfants
puissent bénéficier de la classe là on
en est loin
alors kévin quoi ce leur vient
d'entendre donc pas de gel
hydroalcoolique pas de matériel moins de
professeurs selon alain talleux des
élèves qui se contaminent 1
visiblement d'après ce qu'a constaté à
l'intel également qu'est ce que ça veut
ça donne vous dans les collèges et les
lycées
kevin beausoleil a pas de contamination
chez les jeunes écoutez moi je
contrairement à ce monsieur je ne suis
pas vivre je ne suis pas notamment
compétent pour savoir s'il ya des
contaminations paille par notamment de
certains enseignants qui se sont
contaminées
ben moi j'aimerais bien savoir où donc
quand elle entend notamment c'est dans
nos salles de classe qu'en sait-il je
pense que là il est typiquement dans un
discours idéologique dans un discours
politique où il est en train de mettre
en avant des revendications syndicales
en mélangeant tout on y passait quand
même du protocole sanitaire à la baisse
du nombre de postes de professeurs à je
ne sais pas trop quoi donc voyez on est
toujours dans ce petit syndicalisme à la
moelle moi le noeud qui n'a plus aucune
audience notamment dans la salle des
professeurs la vérité c'est que le fsue
n'a que le mot intérêts de l'élève à la
bouche et qu'au final il fait tout pour
que ces derniers ne puissent pas
bénéficier d'un enseignement normal la
vérité c'est qu'ils sont sans arrêt en
train de défendre ces syndicalistes
notamment le service public de
l'éducation et par leurs revendications
ces extravagantes et leurs grèves à
répétition ils font tous notamment pour
que ce service public ne puisse pas
fonctionner la vérité c'est qu'il le
fsue passe son temps à se réclamer de la
république alors qu'ils n'ont de cesse
il n'a de cesse de sacrifier l'intérêt
général sur l'autel de leurs petites
revendications syndicales et de leur
corporatisme ventripotent la vérité
c'est que ce syndicaliste n'est
absolument pas si vous voulez dans la
république il utilise notamment ses
élèves pour faire de la petite politique
puisque derrière ce qui est visé c'était
dimanche jean michel blanquer rc sa
politique et c'est aussi la politique d'
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il y en a
marre de ces idées au locle les
professeurs de terrain ne constate pas
ce que dit ce monsieur il y a en effet
dû gel hydroalcoolique dans nos salles
de classe il ya des masques qui fournit
donc à un moment donné il faut que tu as
quitté notamment les bureaux du snes et
quitter les bureaux du syndicat pour
aller un peu voir ce qui se passe dans
nos salles de classe dont 13 de ces
petites ces petits discours syndicaux
qui n'intéressent que ceux qui les
premiers à l'antenne je vous donne je
vous donne la réponse sur ces reproches
de sur le syndicalisme
sur le syndicaliste que vous représentez
quelle est votre réponse à l'appel alors
la première chose c'est que sur les
chiffres ce ne sont pas mes chiffres
monsieur ce sont les chiffres de
l'inspecteur d'académie
donc je les invente pas c'est les
chiffres qui nous faudrait par
l'administration
donc voilà les chiffres du concours vous
pouvez les consulter sur le ministère
sur le site du ministère donc vous
constaterez aussi que c'est la même
chose
voilà donc ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point le ministère lui dit
nationale ne suis que sur nationale ne
fournit pas de gel hydroalcoolique
c'est faux alors peut-être que vous en
avez eu dans votre nom mais vous en avez
peut-être eu dans votre dans votre
établissement
mais ce n'est pas fournie par
l'établissement oui vous avez bien ça
montre une disparité messieurs messieurs
est ce que finalement ça ne montre pas
une disparité entre les écoles allez-y
je vous en prie sur le syndicalisme
ventripotent jeu je le remercie je vous
remercie pour le pour le compliment dont
je ne suis pas un syndicat syndicaliste
ventripotent je suis je suis encore
relativement svelte je n'ai pas besoin
de vous montrer je suis en classe
monsieur j'enseigne auprès d'elle j'ai
un cm1 cm2 g29 et l'aide voilà donc je
ne suis pas détaché est loin loin de la
classe c faut donc je suis enseignant
depuis presque 20 ans et je suis en
classe depuis toujours
voilà c'est le le point suivant et alors
par rapport au fait que je ne représente
rien je suis désolé monsieur mais le
style ni ppc cinq ans 4000 adhérents sur
350 mille enseignants le premier degré
donc le jour où ils trouveraient
l'équivalent dans un parti politique
dans une quelconque syndicat la rodia
des syndicats qui sont très
représentatifs mais je crois que 54
mille enseignants pour 350 me soit 54
mille enseignants syndiqués sur la
profession je pense que nous
représentons et je peux l'assumer nous
représentons le le premier degré et vous
pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais
n'empêche qu'on à 54 mille personnes qui
tous les ans versent une cotisation et
qui nous suivent et qui nous
accompagnent et ils font partie et qui
font le syndicat monsieur est ce qu'il
n'ya pas autant d'organisations face à
la crise du coc vie de 19 qui lie à
autant d'établissements kevin bossuet
vous vous avez donc du gel
hydroalcoolique
visiblement vous êtes satisfait des
conditions dans lesquelles vous
travaillez ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'alain talleux effet finale finalement
est-ce que c'est pas le lier au chef de
l'établissement
est ce que chacun il va pas un petit peu
de sa formule au fond n'ont absolument
pas je crois qu'il ya un protocole
sanitaire qui est scrupuleusement
respectées dans l'établissement
j'enseigne en seine saint denis dans ces
territoires perdus de la république pour
reprendre cette expression est dans nos
établissements en seine-saint-denis on a
évidemment du gel hydroalcoolique on a
évidemment des masses quant à la
représentation aujourd'hui du
syndicalisme enseignant c'est ainsi que
n'importe quoi il faut voir pourquoi les
enseignants adhère notamment un syndicat
notamment c'est pour essayer d'accélérer
leur mutation c'est pour faire en sorte
si vous voulez d'avoir des petites
astuces pour améliorer notamment leurs
conditions au niveau des mutations la
vérité c'est que dans l'enseignement
il ya seulement 20 à 25 % de taux de
syndicalisation ce qui fait que ce
monsieur le dit lui même il est
complètement minoritaires et ne
représentent pas notamment ses collègues
et dans un discours politique dans un
discours idéologique que je pense qu'il
confond notamment sa salle déplace avec
une arène politique quand il ya un
enseignant responsable quand on à
l'intérêt général je lis au corps on
fait tout pour défendre notamment la
république qui ont fait tout pour
défendre l'accès à tous à l'éducation il
ya en seine-saint-denis quatre mille
enfants des enfants qui n'ont pas
retrouvé les salles de classe ils sont
complètement perdus ou sans ses enfants
donc pendant que monsieur est en train
de défendre notamment des petites
revendications syndicales des
enseignants sur les terrains et c'est
notamment d'aller récupérer ses enfants
voilà la république ses terres en sorte
que tout le monde puisse rentrer alors
certes il ya un risque sanitaire il est
minorée grâce au protocole qui est mise
en place
moi j'aimerais bien que ce monsieur mais
tout le temps en avant l'intérêt de la
république l'intérêt général plutôt que
ces petites revendications syndicales
qui je le redis ne représente plus rien
en salle des professeurs alain tanner
pour vous le mot de la fin on le
rappelle quand même vous disiez ou au
début vous disiez quand même que
l'importance était tous les élèves un
puisse revenir dans les classes le mot
de la fin pour voix l'interrompt
oui effectivement il faut que tous les
élèves dans les classes et d'ailleurs
c'est le cas moi j'ai mangé mes 29
élèves dans la glace donc je sais
effectivement qui s droit où les enfants
font pas pu revenir mais c'est vrai
parce qu'à part d'enseignants tout
simplement et secret sait pas et c'est
pas la peau des enseignants c'est de la
faute du ministère qui n'a pas prévu que
les enseignants voilà donc ça c'est le
conte aussi peut-être sur lequel il
faudra terminer
et puis surtout moi j'aimerais que mes
élèves et une scolarité toute l'année je
voulais j'ai pas envie que ça s'arrête
encore une fois comme l'année dernière
parce que
pour des raisons de sanitaires ils
pourront pas avoir classe moi j'ai envie
de pouvoir continuer à faire classe avec
eux en présentiel parce que l'école
c'est ça et la république c'est ça et je
suis un défenseur ardent de la
république mais pour ça peut-être qu'il
faut juste juste penser à se donner les
moyens de scolariser les enfants
correctement et donc si cette donnée les
moyens c'est peut-être effectivement
plus d'enseignants plus de locaux pour
réduire le nombre de deux groupes pour
éviter la diffusion du virus
et puis effectivement quoi des masques
de qualité du gel hydroalcoolique dans
tous les établissements s'ils le font
etc etc et la bomba on attend toujours
et bien en tout cas un grand merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté le
principe du débat ce soir en direct sur
rt france merci à vous kevin bosse fait
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire en seine saint denis vous
nous l'avez dit merci à vous alain pas
le fait d'être professeur et
cosecrétaire snuipp fsu du nord